التعاون الامني والاقتصادي وتحقيق السلام
والاستقرار لدى دول جنوب شرق اسيا من ابرز
القضايا التي ناقشتها قمه الولايات
المتحده مع رابطه امم جنوب شرق اسيا وقال
الرئيس الامريكي ان اسيان هي في صميم
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه مع منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادي وكشف عن اطلاق اتفاقيه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله مع اسيا
من المناخ الى الامن الصحيه سنطلق منصه
بين الولايات المتحده واسيا من اجل تحقيق
فوائد الشراكه في الاستثمار العالمي في
الاتصال والبنيه التحتيه لدول اسيان من
خلال هذه المنصه احسن نطور مشاريعا معا
بناء على حاجتكم من اجل توفير بنيه تحتيه
المستدامه عاليه المستوى
ايضا مع قاده اسيا حرب روسيا الوحشيه في
اوكرانيا
الصين ايضا تحتل اولوياتنا على جدول اعمال
الرئيس الامريكي حيث ذكر البيت الابيض عقب
اجتماع جمع الرئيس الامريكي برئيس الوزراء
الكمبودي ان البيت الابيض يعرب على
المخاوفيفه ازاء الانشطه التي يقوم بها
الجيش الصيني في جزيره في جزيره اريام
الكمبوديه المطله على خليجي تايلاندا وشدد
البيت الابيض على ضروره الشفافيه الكامله
في ما يتعلق بهذه الانشطه
في الجزيره